any of you guys enjoyed the old far
cries man there's one constant question
a lot of people always ask is should i
get the next far cry am i going to enjoy
the next far cry i know they they're
sicker than things out there man but
we're gonna review that game today but
before we get on to video definitely go
ahead and subscribe to the iron lures
podcast channel you can always catch us
every sunday at 11am or 1pm when it's
not the football season and don't forget
to go there and follow me at
lordaddictiop on twitter without any
further ado let's review far cry 6 for
the xbox series x
[Music]
what's going to you guys lord addict
here coming at you for another review
today we're going to be reviewing far
cry 6 on the iron lords podcast and the
only question i have is they're going to
get that iron sill from us is it going
to be that game that the iron lords
podcast suggests for its audience to
play and that's the biggest question but
the first thing we're gonna talk about
in this review is the story of far cry
6. is it good is it average is it bad
what is the story lord addict actually
the story was pretty good i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna like say it's the most
amazing story that's ever been in the
far cry games because i do think that
for the most part their stories are do
hit pretty well and that's mainly
because they always choose a very
fantastic antagonist that really brings
out the story of the game i will say
that in terms of
what the narrative of the game is it's
one of those things where it's like
let's take back the land let's get
everyone united what you would really
expect but it's not really necessarily
about something that we've seen over and
over again it's about how they do it do
they do it differently and they don't
really do it differently either we'll be
honest with you but you know what they
do they do just enough to keep you
interested in the story and what's going
on in far cry 6 they want you to know
how to build onto this universe and find
out really the conclusion of this story
and i don't really have any real so
issues with the story of far cry 6
besides maybe i felt like the the climax
the very end could have ended a little
bit differently not really gonna go too
much into that because i'm not gonna
spoil anything but you guys will know
once you beat the game now let's talk
about the performance of this game and
let's talk about how this game looked in
terms of graphics i felt like they did a
really good job in terms of what this
game looks like how it performed i'm
playing on the xbox series x so i
definitely understand if there's people
that's going to be skeptical coming into
this not knowing exactly how the last
gen consoles work how the ps4 works and
how the xbox one and xbox one x works
but for me on the xbox series x besides
maybe i think the cinematics of the game
ran at 30 frames i don't know it just
looked like a little clippy i don't know
if it was 30 frames or if it was some
kind of screen tearing or something
going on there i don't know all the
terms for the graphics stuff but for the
most part i have no issues now this game
is co-op and i did run it with a friend
and for the most part that was a pretty
seamless thing too now it does look like
the second person that joins the person
that's hosting the event or hosting the
session all he's going to keep
throughout this is he's going to keep
what he unlocks any type of cars or
anything related to the vehicles in the
game that he delivers to the little
pickup spots he's not going to get
anything related to story progression
which is a little disappointing i think
if you host something at the beginning
of the game you should be able to play
the whole game and keep that story
content but i'm not a developer i don't
know how hard that is you know maybe
they have issues with if you join
someone's session that overwrites your
session so you know if that's the case
give people an option for that give
people an option if they want to play
the whole story with someone that is
going to overwrite their save file or
give them the option that only the
progression and the add-on locks come
over with you to your save now keep in
mind you do continue to keep pretty much
everything you get at the other one it's
just like i said it's pretty much
strictly just story progression but keep
in mind when you do all this stuff in
your friend's game and you come over to
your game you're gonna have those newer
weapons that you really shouldn't have
at the beginning of the wet game you're
going to have higher ranking armor and
stuff that you really shouldn't have in
the beginning of the game so i feel like
you know this is a good middle ground
maybe they should have given a little
bit more options but i'm not going to go
too much into it and i feel like this is
something that you guys would enjoy
especially for co-op experience it's
really fun to go in there and just you
know ride a helicopter with your friend
the majority of their stuff if not all
of their vehicles have dual
seats because they knew that a lot of
people were going to be playing this
game in a co-op experience and i know
there's a lot of people out there that
feel like if a game is any co-op and
whatsoever it's going to take away from
its single player experience the single
player story experience but i didn't
really feel that to be honest i felt
like they built this game as a single
player game and they put mechanics into
the game to really enlighten and
heighten the co-op experience so for
instance if you decide to play this
whole game by yourself you're going to
enjoy the game and if you
invite one of your friends to help you
do some of the stuff you're going to
even enjoy mo because it's always funner
with friends and i appreciate the
options i appreciate the fact that
they're giving you the option to play
this with your friend now you guys know
what it is man this is my favorite
portion of almost every review let's
talk about the game play in far cry 6. i
honestly feel like the gameplay is where
this game excels by far it is a nice
time playing far cry 6. there's multiple
different vehicles and they all feel
nice the guns feel great they feel solid
they feel like their actual
objects in your hand the co-op
experience on top of this makes it
really fun now i do feel like some of
the stealth mechanics in this game it's
not real good towards you know the
beginning portion of the game but once
you unlock more stuff you're able to do
stuff a lot more stealth like in this
game but just don't really feel like
you're going to do everything stealth
coming out the gate on far cry 6. i'm
sure if you have enough patience and you
have a lot of experience in these type
of games you can and to to your point
myself i do as well i just felt like
sometimes when you take someone out in
far cry 6 it's like the other people
naturally know he's down and then
they'll be sitting there for 10 minutes
but the moment you take out that dude
they decide to go on a walk and find his
dead body so just be very very aware
when you're doing stuff you're clearing
out these objectives now i'm sure some
of you were like lord addict what's the
type of styles that you could play in
far cry 6 is it really open to how you
want to play not necessarily how the
game wants you to play it are they very
good with that types of mechanics and i
would have to say yes for the most part
everything i wanted to do in this game
and how i wanted to play this game i
didn't feel like there wasn't some type
of gun or some type of mechanic that was
in the game that wouldn't let me play
the way i wanted to play the game i will
say that ubisoft when they make the far
cry games they do a really good job
making sure that if you want to play
that game a certain way you have access
to the game that certain way and i have
to give my hats off to them because i do
feel like a lot of games do it all one
way or all the other for instance you
know they have decent stealth mechanics
in the game but it's nothing serious and
if you do get seen on these games you
might as well just restart the
checkpoint because they're going to come
at you so hard and the game wasn't
designed to be seen that it feels a
little bit unbalanced in terms of if i
can play it stealth like can i go in
their guns blazing and if i go on guns
blazing am i allowed to play the game
stuff like it i felt like far cry 6 and
for the most part the majority of the
far crys have always did a good job at
letting me play the game how i want to
play and as far as this stuff to do in
far cry i mean it's not really changed
much in terms of far cry you got your
objectives on here you got your
checkpoints you got your bases enemy
bases that you can liberate and take
over you got all of these things on here
that make sense towards the narrative
you want to clear as much of the map as
possible so you can take the fight back
to the meme dictator you want to be able
to take this country back for the
natives and another thing i can really
hand it off to the far cry 6 team i'm
not going to try to pronounce their name
because i'm going to butcher it is the
fact that the music and really you know
how people sound sound really good i
don't feel like you know i heard the
same person more than once they everyone
felt really nice out that especially the
audio you know any types of audio going
into this game from the gun shooting to
the music playing and the main
protagonist singing in the car while
you're driving down the road it's the
little attention to detail that i think
a lot of you are going to really
appreciate from this game i mean there's
even epic music epic missions pretty
much everything about the game is solid
man i can't really find too much to
nitpick about this game as far as far
cries comparing to other far crys i
would probably say far cry 3 is still a
goat in terms of what far cry is the
best and maybe that's a lot of nostalgia
on my hat my part maybe because i really
enjoyed far cry back then when i first
started really diving into the far cry
franchise that that's obviously going to
be my favorite but regardless of far cry
theory is my favorite i feel like far
cry 6 gives us a run for its money i do
feel like the far cry 3 in terms of
character development they had a little
bit more going for them in that but that
doesn't take away from far cry 6 i
honestly feel like far cry 6 is the
second best in the franchise i know a
lot of you might disagree on that a lot
of people like far cry 4 and 5. and i
really jump in too much of far cry 1 and
2 but as far as far cries this is a
solid experience and a solid entry into
the franchise and i recommend everyone
go out here and buy this game man you
know but hey if you guys feel
uncomfortable paying 60 70 dollars and
the reason i say 70 dollars because i
don't really know what it costs on the
xbox series s
or x or the ps5 i'm assuming it's all 60
but i'm not don't don't quote me on that
man but i do think it's worth it
regardless what the price point is now i
think i had a solid experience with this
game and i think a lot of you would
enjoy it too if you like good stories
that are told well gameplay that
highlights that story and you know just
general atmosphere in general this game
looks great then i think this game is
for you far cry 6 is for you go out
there and get it but anyway that's the
review on far cry 6. i think the game's
a solid experience i do think it's worth
the money that they're asking for you
can get you about i would say anywhere
from 25 to 40 hours depending on how
much you do in the game i did a good
amount but i didn't clear everything in
the map i never really do when it comes
to far cry games but there is a lot of
substance here to how much you're going
to spend versus what you're going to get
but anyway that's the review guys tell
me in the comment section below did you
guys enjoy far cry 6 if you're coming
here after you've played the game and if
you're coming here before you play the
game to see if you want to validate
spending that money tell me what you
guys think in the comment section below
and far cry 6 is totally going to get
that iron stamp and until the next
review this is lord addict i'm out outta
here
[Music]